بعد سنوات غياب احمد فهمي يعود بقوه
لرمضان في سر الباتع وبين استوديو 23 وسقط
سهوا نجم الكوميديا خالد المظفر يطل هذا
الشهر والبطولات النسائيه بتنور شاشات
رمضان واحدىهن البطل العروس ماريتا
الحلاني اهلا بكم
رمضان كريم مشاهدينا وكل عام وانتم بالف
خير تفاعلكم بينطلق معاكم في اولى حلقات
رمضان في موعدنا الرمضاني 12 منتصف الليل
بتوقيت السعوديه ولساعه كامله على مدار
الشهر الفضيل اقول لكم بسم الله نبدا
الموسم
مسلسل من اضخم انتاجات رمضان السنه عمل
بميزانيه ضخمه وكميه نجوم هائله نحن
بنتكلم عن اكثر من ستين نجم ونجمه مصريين
وعرب المسلسل من اخراج المخرج الكبير خالد
يوسف وماخوذ من روايه للاديب الراحل يوسف
ادريس يعني العمل عامل عامل صدى كبير من
وقت الاعلان عنه بيتكلم عن فتره الحمله
الفرنسيه على مصر واحداثه بتدور في فترتين
زمنيتين ومثل ما قلنا كميه النجوم في فعلا
مو طبيعيه ومنهم احمد فهمي احمد اللي
تعودنا عليه في الادوار الكوميديه هذه
المره بيطلع خارج اطارها وبيفاجئنا كلنا
وماخذ دور بطوله في سر الباتع بشخصيه حامد
اللي بيبحث عن لغز مقام السلطان حامد اللي
الناس كلها بتلجا له عشان تحقق امنياتها
وخلال رحله بحثوا عن اللغز بيلاقي ورقه
حفره داخل المقام مكتوب عليها باللغه
الفرنسيه وبيصب كل جهده عشان يعرف ايش
المكتوب في الورقه المسلسل من اول حلقه
بيوعد بالكثير ومشوق الجمهور انه يتابعوا
احداثه القادمه
انا بدور على حكايه السلطان
مدد يا حبيبي السلطان
ملك يا حابب دلوقتي انا بحبها كانها من
دمي
ايه قصه الحب الحلوه دي
وهينضم الينا النجم احمد فهمي اهلا فيك
معنا يا احمد كل عام وانت بالف خير يا رب
وانت طيبه يا ساره ربنا يخليك كل سنه وانت
طيبه وانت طيب ان شاء الله ومبروك العمل
صراحه من اول حلقه حسينا انه احنا امام
عمل ضخم جدا صراحه اذا تحكيلنا انت من
البدايه بعد طول غياب ايش اللي يرجعك لهذه
العمل
انا كان بقى لي سنتين دي ثالث سنه بمضي في
اخر لحظه لاني كنت عايز اخش بحاجه قويه
وحاجه مكتوبه كويس وحاجه مبزول فيها مجهود
من الاول وفعلا كنت بعمل مسلسل تاني خالص
في الاول وبعد كده لقيته استاذ خالد كلمني
وشركه الانتاج المتاح طبعا
فرحت لهم فقالوا لي احنا عايزين نعمل
مسلسل سر الباتع استاذ خالد يوسف فقلت لهم
انا ماضي مسلسل تاني قالوا لي بس اقعد
واتكلم مع استاذ فلما قعدت اتكلمت انا
عارف ان هي روايه يوسف ادريس فقعدت اتكلمت
معاه فلقيت ان هي فرصه يعني ما تتفوتش ومش
بتيجي
في العمر يعني كتير ان انت تعمل عمل
بالضخامه دي يبقى فيه ميزانيه كبيره اعتقد
هو الميزانيه الاكبر في رمضان
[موسيقى]
في كل الاجيال كبيره جدا
فما ترددتش بصراحه وفوق مع خالد يوسف هو
مخرج كبير
وعنده مدرسته الخاصه وطريقته الخاصه
فما ترددتش بصراحه يعني طبعا المسلسل هذا
اصلا يعني عوده كمان هو قويه بالنسبه له
بس انا في شيء لفتني صراحه احمد كل
الفنانين لمن كل سنه يعني احنا بنعمل كل
رمضان بنشوف بنقابل الفنانين وكل حاجه
كلهم دائما بيلبسوا بيصوروا بيصوروا لاخر
رمضان انت مخلص تصوير ايش المعجزه هذه ده
انا عايز اقول لك انا اصلا بره مصر انا في
باريس
يعني ايه معجزه كيف صار هذا الشيء دخلتوا
تصوير بدري في تنظيم ايش السر
مبدئيا اول حاجه بتتعمل لان معظم في غلطه
بنقع فيها كلنا ان انت بتطور مثلا بعشرين
حلقه او بخمس او بعشره وتكتب وانت على
الهوا فما تبقاش لاحق وبتكمل لحد اخر
رمضان خالد يوسف كان مصر ان الحق الواحد
وتلاتين حلقه احنا 31 بيكونوا مكتوبين من
قبل ما نخش نصلي فعشان كده كان عامل جدول
مظبوط جدا وهو كان مصر من الاول ان احنا
مش هنخش رمضان احنا هنخلص كلنا قبل رمضان
فانا مخلص تقريبا بقى لي يعني خلصت قبل
رمضان بحوالي اسبوع 10 ايام
رغم صعوبه المسلسل المسلسل صعب جدا اتكلمي
على حققتين زمانيتين
ب 600 ممثل اساسي منهم 60
او اقصد 600 ممثل موجودين ما بين ادوار
اساسيه وثانويه و60 اساسيين الستين اساسين
انت بتتكلمي فيهم دول تقريبا كلهم نجوم
لا هي واحده من الاشياء اللي لافته طبعا
زوجتك النجمه هنا الزاهد طبعا تح يه كتبت
حطت لك بوست على انستجرام وكانت بتقول فيه
انه الله يوفقك على تعبك الشهور اللي فاتت
وكانت يعني بتوجهلك طبعا التحيه وانه يعني
اللي بينفهم من البوست حقها كمان انه يحط
كذا بوست طبعا انه كان متعب التصوير
لا لا كان موت يعني عمليات بحريه المسلسل
ده من اصعب الحاجات اللي صورتها هو نفسه
خالد يوسف ما كانش بينام يعني كان بيطلع
من
الاوردر بتاع العصري اللي هو انا بشتغل
فيه بعدين بيطلع في اللي هو فيه احمد
السعدني ما اطلع على المونتاج وبعدين
السنتين اللي فاتوا دول كلهم انا عملت
ثلاث اعمال لسه ما تعرضوش يمكن ده اول
واحد سره الباتا وفي بعد كده السفاح بعد
رمضان دي قصه حقيقيه برده مسلسل
على شاهد ان شاء الله ان شاء الله وبعد
كده في فيلم مستر اكس برضو كان بقى لي
سنتين بحضر فيه
ان شاء الله
فكان الموضوع مجهد جدا يعني والتلاته
جونيورز مختلفه تماما عن بعض لكن سر هو
هو المسلسل مش بس هو مسلسل
بيتكلم عن الهويه المصريه فقط لا هو
بيتكلم كمان على
في اجتماعيات كتير وفي حاجات كتير تانيه
فهو انت عارفه خالد يوسف ومخرج جماهيري
جدا وهو قادر يعمل في مسلسل واحد على
مستوى الكتابه فالتنفيذ كان صعب جدا لا
يعرف يلعب اللعبه اللي هو يكون فيه
المسلسل عمق بس نفس الوقت يكون برضو مسلسل
ناجح جماهيريا طيب بس واحده من الاشياء
كمان اللي يعني مختلفه في هذا العمل انه
الناس عاده متعوده عليك في الكوميديا اكثر
احنا شفناك الان بطريقه مختلفه تماما هل
نقدر نقول انه خلاص يعني انت بتودع
الكوميديا وشاقك خط جديد يعني
لا لا خالص هو اللي حصل في فيلم العارف
كان من سنه ونص او سنتين مع احمد
نجاح كبير الحمد لله وكان كان بدايه ان
انا اوسع قماشتي او ان انا اقدر اعمل
حاجات تانيه مختلفه فالحمد لله الدور لقى
يعني طابول كبير عند الناس والفيلم نفسه
ناجح نجاح كبير فبدا يجي لي ادوار من
النوعيه دي كتير سواء السفاح بس انا هرجع
تاني ان شاء الله في في عيد الاضحى في
فيلم مستر اكس هو فيلم كوميدي لا الفتره
الجايه ان شاء الله هيكون فيها تنويه كتير
يعني
وفي شايله حضانه ناس في اول حلقه انه
بيظهر اخوك كمان كريم فهمي معك
بس يعني ترى اول شيء في البدايه لما انا
بدات اتفرج على المسلسل ان المسلسل لاحمد
فهد فجاه يطلع لي كريم فهمي فيعني حصل
شويه اتلخبطه يعني هذه كانت مقصوده عشان
الشبه
اه استاذ خالد
كان يعني دور الاب هو ضيف شرف هيظهر
الحلقه الاولى وهيموت استاذ خالد قال لي
انا عايز كريم يعمل الدور لو بيقدر يجي
لنا ضيف شرف يعني فكلمت كريم فوافق على
طول وجه عمل وكان حلو جدا بصراحه عشان
كمان الشبه فهي ماشيه حلو والدور صعب جدا
لانه
بتتكلم في مشهدين او تلاته عايز توصل منهم
كل حاجه وكلهم كان فيهم عاليه جدا وفيهم
لحظات حلوه فكريم عملوا حلو بصراحه على
سيره كريم احمد بما انه يعني انت موجود
يعني همم كمان خلينا نتكلم شويه عنه هو
الفتره الماضيه حقق نجاحك جدا كبير في
مسلسل ازمه منتصف العمر الكل كان بيتكلم
عنه بس في نفس الوقت المسلسل عمل الجدل
رهيب رهيب رهيب وكان فيه هجوم ومش عارفه
ايش الكلام ده كله تحس انه ان ظلم ولا تحس
انه لا هم رفعوا الدوز في المسلسل ولا كيف
تحس
بالعكس
المسلسل نجح نجاح كبير جدا بس حسيت انه
ظلم في الهجوم اللي صار عليه بالعكس
الهجوم ده بعتبره نجاح يعني انت في الاخر
ما فيش حاجه ناجحه ناجحه الا وهيبقى عليها
جدل كبير ما فيش حاجه ناجحه بتعدي كده
مرور الكرام يا اما بقى تكون بناجحه
بالجان والكلام ده
لا بالعكس الجدل اللي اتعمل عليه ده شايف
ان هو مؤشر لنجاحه وبادي الفيلم كمان اللي
كريم نازل به بعد كده انا لحبيبي نزل بعدي
على طول فيلم هو في عيد الحب 14/2
والفيلم لا نجاح كبير برده جدا يعني اول
ما نزل متصدر يعني لا هي يبدو السنه سندكم
ما شاء الله يا احمد انا لسه المشوار طويل
لسه 30 حلقه ولسه السفاح بعدين لسه مستر
اكس ان شاء الله ان شاء الله هي هنا كتبت
في بوست انه السنه ان شاء الله دي سنتك
ونحنا يعني متوقعين هذا الشيء لانه
البدايه يعني الان قويه في سر البعث
الصراحه
الافعال الحلوه جدا
ان انا شفت المسلسل صراحه يعني يعني
المتوقع اللي جاي صراحه كلنا في انتظار
القادم يعني
كمان حابه اسالك على قصه التتر كان مختلف
احمد حسان عن يعني اللي متعودين عليه
يعني هل انتم تشاورتوا مع المخرج خالد
يوسف قبلها انه ما تظهر اساميكم في
البدايه او كيف تم الموضوع انا من الاول
يعني من الاول انا مضيت يمكن اول واحد في
المسلسل فمضيت وكان يعني كان كان في في
العقد ان كل واحد هيبقى مكانه فين في
التتر وبعدين انت عندك نجوم كتير جدا وناس
كتير جدا انا مش بتكلم على مين الاول ومين
التاني انا بكلمك حتى بعد كده يعني في
الثالث والرابع والخامس والحاجات دي
هتلاقي فيه دوشه كتير لان كلهم نجوم
والله انا حتى لما جم سالوني قلت لهم انا
شايف ان يعني زي
يعني بره بيعملوا كده في الافلام بتاعه
بره في حاجه دلوقتي قوي يعني
وكل الناس دي نجوم وشافتها معروفه
واساميها معروفه
اعتقد ان ده كان الحل المناسب يعني
وريح الجميع وفي الاخر المهمه مشتها ومهمه
جوده العمل يعني لا صح هو يعني حل يعني
كان لو كان في مشاكل هتصير فهو حلها
وبالفعل زي ما انت قلت انتم كلكم نجوم
يعني الواحد خلاص لما بيشوفكم بيعرفكم
احمد انا يعني من اشد المتابعين لاعمالك
من اول ما بدات من اشد المعجبين فعمالك
فجدا حابه التطور الان اللي انت جالس
بتسوي وحابه المسلسل جدا من البدايه يعني
وان شاء الله حنكمل معك الشهر ونتابعه
بالتوفيق
ربنا يخليك ميرسي جدا جدا وكل سنه وانت
طيبه وانت طيب وانبسط في باريس
يلا مع السلامه شكرا لك كان معنا النجم
احمد فهمي
خالد المظفر نجم الكوميديا بيشارك هذا
الموسم الرمضاني الحالي في استوديو 23
واللي سبق وشارك في اجزاءه السابقه
استوديو 21 كمان
جديد مشاهدينا الكرام برنامجنا اعمل خير
وقطه تتوقع موزين الفلوس وين
اول مره اشوف ركبه لها شنب
[تصفيق]
ة الفريق
كله
[موسيقى]
يعني لا يمكن ان يحدث
وايد اكبر من الحدث
بيشارك في بطوله استديو 23 سنه فهو كمان
بيقوم ببطوله مسلسل اخر اللي هو سقط سهوا
واللي هو كمان صاحب فكرته شارك في تاليف
كمان وبيشاركوا في بطولته وفنان الكوميديا
المصري حمدي المرغني وبيتكلم العمل عن
صديقين بتصير معاهم كثير من الاحداث ليش
اسمه سقط سهوا راح نعرف مع بعض بس بعد ما
نشوف برومو العمل
هذا وين المرضى والمراجعي
الدكتور ولا علامه علي بيومي الح
اصل عن الايز
و
عباره عن منو هذه ممكن تصمينا لما احنا
قاعدين بالنا شويه حلوين وبنتسامر وبنشرب
قهوتنا امال مين بيعالج العيانين
يا ابو
قصتنا يكون فيها اكشن
من الكويت النجم خالد المظفر اهلا فيك
معنا خالد كل عام وانت بالف خير
اهلا كل عام وانتم بخير يا ساره ومبارك
عليك الشهر ومبارك على اخواننا واخواتنا
الساده المشاهدين
اجمعين اجمعين وانت ما شاء الله السنه
متالق بعملين خلينا نبتدي باستديو 23 عوده
مره اخرى
مبسوطين انتم يعني على النجاح
اللهم لك الحمد والله هذه هي التجربه
الثالثه في عمل استوديو 23 مع اخواني
النجوم اخوي حبيب الحبيب وعبد العزيز
النصار وخالد الفراج وماجد المطرب وسامي
حازم وجميع الاخوه والفنانين والفنانات
اللي شاركوا في جميع الفقرات للامانه
العمل كوميدي بسيط الناس حابته بعفويته
بفغراته يعني فاحنا سنه مع سنه نجدد العهد
مع شاشه العرب ام بي سي ان احنا نقدم هذا
العمل الكوميدي الهدف منه هو فقط الضحكه
والابتسامه
اتمنى الكل ياخذها بصدر الرحم لا طبعا وهو
اصلا انتم اليوم من اول حلقه ترند
والمقاطع جلسه بتنزل من الحلقه ما شاء
الله عليكم بس انا انت قلت ذكرت اسماء
طبعا فريق العمل وكل التحيه لهم كلهم نجوم
رائعين انا احس انه كواليس التصوير تضحك
اكثر من التصوير نفسه
[ضحك]
لا كلامك صح 100% لان انت قاعد تتعامل مع
كوميديانات يعني وكل واحد لكن اكثر الخاص
فيه يعني عبد العزيز النصار مع حبيب
الحبيب وماجد مطرب يعني
مقالب او يخرب المشاهد فيكم مين اكثر واحد
لا هو بصراحه يعني اكثر واحد احنا عندنا
حركه ما شاء الله عليه الله يحفظه اخونا
حبيب الحبيب احنا نجد تصوير احيانا ثمان
الصبح يكون يعني مالنا خلق نسلم على بعض
نشوف حبيب ما شاء الله
عليها حبيبي وطبعا تحيه
يعني برضو من الشخصيات الرائعه جدا اذا
بدي أكيد انا اخوي يعني عبد العزيز النصار
اوجه له تحيه خصوصا اغلب مشاهد كانت مع
وانا استمتع لما امثل مع عبد العزيز
للامانه
اذا نقلتك على سقطه سهوا لانه هو اللي عمل
اللي جديد بالنسبه لك يعني هذا الموسم اول
شيء ليش اسمه سقط سهوا
سقط سهوا لانه فعلا نحن في شغلات بحياتنا
تكون سقطه سهوا ما كانت هي عن عمد ما
فعلناها واحنا متعمدين
فسقط سهوا هي الكلمه اللي تلخص الحدوته
واللي قاعد يصير بين الشخصيات سقطت سهوا
العمل
كوميدي لايت رومانس دراما راح يكون فيه
مكس
اجواء جديده على الاعمال الكوميديه دائما
العمل الكوميدي تعودنا عليه بالسنين
الاخيره
يعني شنو شايفه يا ساره يعني اكيد انت يا
خالد صح اكيد انت اللي حبيبي حتكون حتقول
انت المؤلف
والمنتجة هذه الشغله نسيتها اكيد يعني
طبعا حتضبط الامور انه كل البنات تحبك انت
اكيد يعني خلص مفهومه تمام يعني احنا كل
مشهد نصور يقول لي يا حمدي حمدي يقول لي
ايه يا عمو خلود
لانه شايف الوضع يعني طب التعاون مع حمدي
اصلا
للامانه والتعاون انا للامانه يعني من
معجبين فرغت مسرح مصر الفرقه اللي اسسها
الاستاذ الكبير اشرف عبد الباقي من خلالها
تعرفنا على النجوم اللي هم محمد عبد
الرحمن توته مصطفى خاطر كلهم نجوم كبار
طبعا علي ربيع حمدي مرغني كل الفنانين
الامانه يعني ما احب انسى احد فيهم
فكانت الفكره ان احنا فعلا يعني دايما
اغلب السنين اللي طافت كنت اعمل دويتو مع
الفنانين اللي بيشبهوني او بنفس دائرتي
كان دايما عندي طموح انه لا ممكن احنا
نعمل عمل ويكون معانا كوميديان بحجم
الفنان الكبير حمدي مرغني ويكون
المكس بين الشخصيتين راكب على الاثنين مش
انه فقط مصري بيمثل مع كويتي ويصير فيهات
على اللهجه لا كان كل شيء مرسوم كنا واحنا
قاعد نقرا الورق في بروفه الطاوله كنا
قاعد نضحك وهذا كان مؤشر حلو ويوم طبقناها
على ارض الواقع المشاهد كنا ايضا قاعد
نضحك فان شاء الله الجمهور يستمتع معانا
بهذه التجربه تجربه كانت بالنسبه لنا
كبيره وكنا قاعد نشتغل لها من قلب والفنان
خالد
لا هو شوف الامانه يعني الحمد لله يقول لك
بعد التعب ان شاء الله يكون نجاح يا رب
فاحنا انا دائما بكل تجربه احب اكون مخلص
واسوي كل شيء على اكمل وجه وكانت للامانه
هي فكره حمدي مرغني والفنان مصطفى خاطر
كان يقول ان انت يا خالد نجم في الكويت
والخليج واحنا معانا الوطن العربي وشمال
افريقيا فلما يكون هذا حلو انه يكون في
عمل يوحد لاثنين صح فان شاء الله تجربت
تنال على اعجابكم ان شاء الله يا رب انت
كاتب هذا العمل او كاتب فكرته من اول من
2015 حسب ما فهمت
صحيح ليش التاخير اذا في هذا كله
والله الامانه يعني يعني خالد المظفر اللي
ب 2023 اكيد هو مو نفس اللي ب 2015
2015 هذه الفكره انا كنت
قروها وايد الفنانين كبار قروها شركات
مونتاج لكن ما كان في احد مؤمن بهذا
الفكره او هذا النص النهوه يرى النور او
ان الفكره حلوه لكن من ثم يوم قررنا انه
يكون معنا الفنان حمدي مرغني فعملت ورشه
مع الاستاذ عبد العزيز سفر وهو لكتب
السيناري والحوار
واعدنا اعداد للناس واعداد للشخصيات
وحاولنا اخلي الشخصيات انضج ونخلي المواقف
احلى وطبيعي يمكن احنا كاتب انا نوعيه من
الكوميديا 2015 مش نفسها هي الحين بالفين
ما كان جاهز انه هو يقدم هذا العمل لانه
هو مش عملكم
26 سنه الان صح
26 ب 2015
كل اللي عندي هنا ما يعرفون
لفيت عليهم
يا خالد انا بقول لك من الان
تخلص بقى اذا المعلومه البسيطه تخلص منهم
من
قدام
بس احنا 18 سنه يعني
كل البنات تحبك يعني
بس يعني
قعدت مع نفسك طب اسمع خالد انا احس انه
يعني قد ايش الان صعب انه الواحد يثبت
نفسه في هذا الوسط يعني ما هو سهل
المنافسه شديده في اسماء جدا كبيره خلاص
مسيطره على السوق شركات انتاج معينه نجم
شاب زيك ايش يقدر يعمل عشان يخترق هذا
السوق
للامانه يعني بكل بساطه اقولها لك ساره
انا خالد مؤمن بالله سبحانه وتعالى بكل
خطوه ومؤمن ان النجاحي من الله ومؤمن انه
على قد ما انت تتعب على قد ما انت تاخذ
انا اليوم خالد ممكن على قولتش ممثل شاب
قاعد اجتهد لاني محسوب على شركه لاني
محسوب على جهه انتاجيه قاعد نقاتل احنا
اليوم كشباب انه مقدم احلى شيء اللهم لك
الحمد ثمره هذا التعب انه التلفزيون
الكويت اخذ عمل سقطه سهوا وهو العمل
الكوميدي من بين نجوم كبار هذه الثقه هم
يشكرون عليها ايضا شركه ام بيس قناه ام بي
سي انه يوم تعطينا الفرصه في عمل 23 وايضا
معانا
اعمالكوميديه فيها نجوم كبار هذا كله يخلي
عندنا مسؤوليه يمكن في واحد شاب ثاني غير
يساره يستانس يفرح لكن انا اشعر
بالمسؤوليه والخوف
ما هو القادم
شنو بتسوي عشان انت تحافظ على هذا الشيء
لكن انا دائما احب اكون اكتف وشغال لا ما
شاء الله عليك يعني حتى ما شاء الله في
مجال المسرحيات يعني خالد الفتره الاخيره
كل مالك بتحاول تعمل مسرحيات واشياء من
هذا النوع بس انت لفتره طويله يعني ارتبط
اسمك بطارق العلي طبعا النجم الكبير يعني
له التحيه طبعا وحسن البلام طبعا له
التحيه
هل بتحس نفسك لازلت اسير لهم او انك انت
ابن هادي للمدرسه حقتهم فانت بتكمل فيها
ولا بتحس انك خلاص خرجت من هذه العباءه
لا والله بالعكس يعني الاثنين اللي انت
تكلمتي عنهم وهم قراب من القلب سوالف
الفنان الكبير طارق العلي والفنان الكبير
حسن البلام انا تعلمت منهم واستفدت منهم
ولا كنت انا راح اقدر كخالد اليوم اني
اكون قائد لعمل كوميدي سواء في المسرح او
في التلفزيون الا من خلال احتكاك مع
الكبار ما راح تكون عندي هذه الكاريزما
ولا القدره الا ان انا محتك معاهم وطحت في
تجارب كثيره والسكت من تجربتهم وعلموني
اللي تعلمته منهم هو اللي الحين انا قاعد
احاول اطبقه مع الفنانين الشباب اللي معاي
قال احاول اطبقه على نفسي قبل الله طبقه
معاهم فبالعكس يعني حتى لو انا دايما ممكن
انا انا يعني هذه نقطتي ان انا من مدرسه
طارق العلي وتعلمت منه واستفدت منه وايضا
الفنان الكبير حسن البلام عنده لون خاص
فيه ومدرسه وتعلمت واستفدت منه لكن انا
دائما شنو اقول اقول هو مش موضوع ان احنا
مدرسه هذا الشخص او هذا الشخص وهو لون
الكوميديا عباره بالنسبه لك الوان اليوم
ابو محمد يقدم لون بو مزيانه يقدم لون
خالد يقدم لون ويجي فنان اخر يقدم
والجمهور له حريه الاختيار ولو لاحظ
الجمهور قاعد يستمتع مع الكل مع كله مره
كنت في هذا الجواب يا خالد
لا هذه الاسئله خليها بخمسه وعشرين سؤال
لما تجي صح خلي لما تجي عندنا ايه ونمسكك
ونلقطك
ايه لانه كان كده جواب دبلوماسي وذكي
وارضيتي كل الناس يلا منتظرينك ان شاء
الله عشان 25 سؤال عشان نزنق اكثر في هذه
المواضيع خالد كل التوفيق وعد مني انه راح
اكون موجود معاي
خالد انت من اروع الشخصيات صراحه اللي في
هذا الوسط نتمنى لك كل التوفيق كان معنا
النجم خالد المظفر شكرا
عشرات الاعمال الدراميه بتشارك في الموسم
الرمضاني السنه ومثل كل سنه الاعمال حقيقه
منوعه بشكل كبير في دراما في كوميديا في
تاريخي وغيره وغيره لكن في ملحوظه جميله
جدا انتبهنا لها في تفاعلكم وهي كميه
الاعمال اللي من بطوله النسائيه طبعا ما
نقدر في تفاعلكم ما نحتفل بهذا الموضوع مو
بس لانه نحن بنقدر الفن والدراما لكن كمان
لاننا من اكبر انصار المراه مثل ما كلكم
عارفين خاصه لو متابعينا من زمان هذه عينه
من اعمال رمضانيه بطولتها نسائيه بامتياز
بما انه كمان نحن مشاهدينا جالسين بنتكلم
عن البطولات النسائيه فعندنا نحن كمان
معنا بطله جديده شابه منوره شاشات رمضان
ماريتا الحلاني اللي في السنوات القليله
هذه طلت علينا كمغنيه واخر كم سنه شفناها
كمان ممثله والسنه مريتا بتشارك في السباق
الرمضاني بمسلسل اسمه عشره عمر من بطولتها
والفنان جو صابر وهو اول مسلسل بدا عرض
حلقاته قبل رمضان بايام المسلسل بيحكي قصه
بنت بسيطه طيبه جميله اسمها بيريلا
بيموتوا اهلها في حادث ماساوي ولكن الام
تحديدا وهي على فراش الموت بتكشف سر خطير
عن البنت ومن هنا بتنطلق الاحداث الدراميه
[موسيقى]
ما عندك تسمم انك تنصحيه
صدقني ما راح اتركك راح ابقى احدك لو شو
ما عملت
قام هي اللي بتربي واللي بتسهر مش اللي
بتولد وبتزت
بصله المسلسل فهي ما حرمت الناس كمان من
صوتها وغنت تتر المسلسل
موجوع من غدر اغلى ناس موجوع
تغفل الاحساس
مكسور قلبي يا هوى وشوفي بعد اكثر
حتى الجرح ماله دواء وكل يوم عم يكبر
مكسور
قلبي وتنضم الينا الفنانه ماريتا الحلاني
اهلا فيك معانا يا ماريتا وكل عام وانت
بالف خير يا رب
رمضان كريم لالك ولكل يلي عم بيحضرونا
ومبروك العمل كمان مبروك البطوله يعني عمل
واضح انه مميز والكل بدا يتابعوا قبل
رمضان هل في اي سبب انكم قررتوا يعني
تخرقوا العاده وتبداوا قبل رمضان
اول شيء مرتي كتير على الحكي الحلو قبل ما
سمعته كنت عم تحكي عنه يعني انبسطت كثير
بكلامك وان شاء الله يعني الناس تحب العمل
ونحن بلشنا قبل بوقت لانه المسلسل من اكثر
من 30 حلقه صحيح اوكي فانتم كنتوا عاملين
حساب انه على نهايه رمضان بتخلصوا عادي
لانكم بتكونوا بادئين من قبل يعني
صاح ويمكن يبقى يعني ايام العيد كمان يعني
معقول اوكي طيب ايش اللي جذبك في هذا
العمل مريتا
هلا انا اول ما قريت الناس حبيت القصه
كتير يعني قصه قصه
بنت متبنينه مضيعه امها يعني في قصه شي
جديد لالي يعني ما بيشبه الاعمال يلي
قدمتها قبل والشخصيه بيرلا كمان شخصيه
مختلفه
فحسيت انه انه ليش لا يعني حلو شارك بهذا
العمل
وبالاخر النتيجه حتى كتير مبسوطه يعني هلا
عم بحضر ومبسوطه كتير ومبسوطه بتفاعل
الناس كمان
لانه في دراما كثير يعني مع كل حلقه جلسه
الدراما بتزيد اكثر واكثر بس كمان اللافت
طبعا كمان في العمل امريكي وانت قبل كده
مشاركه في اعمال اللي هي اللي بيسموها
المشتركه يعني السوريه اللبنانيه هذا
العمل العمل لبناني انت كنت حريصه يعني
انه
تشاركي في عمل لبناني كنوع من الدعم
الدراما اللبنانيه ولا انه لا الموضوع
عادي حسب ما يجي يعني العمل
هلا هو اكيد بيجي عروض وانا بقرا بهمنا
اول شيء النص بهمنا دوري بهمني كتير
العوامل يعني بتاثر وبحب كمان يكون عم
بقدم شي مختلف ما كنا عم باخد نفس الدور
مثلا وكمان لانه انتاج لبناني ومع شركه
مروه جروب للاستاذ مروان حداد يلي هو
اعطاني اول فرصه بطوله وقت تصورنا مسلسل
حكايتي وانعرض سنه الماضي فانا حبيت كرر
هالتجربه معه وكمان الظروف يلي عنا بلبنان
يعني حلو نشوف انه في شركات بعدها عم تقدم
اعمال والناس يعني عم تحضر فاكيد يعني في
دعم هون كمان مسلسل
تفضلي
كنت عم بقول انه قبل بارلو عشره عمر صورت
مسلسل اسمه نزيف كان مشترك يعني فيه كان
معنا ممثلين كبار سوريين كمان من العراق
فصورت هيك وهيك ما عندها مشكله ايوه هو ما
عندك مشكله وكان هذا الشيء كمان واضح حتى
في 2020 والكلام هذا كله وحقق دورك وقتها
يعني صدى كبير جدا بس لا زالت الناس بتقول
انه الاعمال المشتركه انجح واكثر انتشارا
بتتفقي مع هذا الشيء
لا انا برايي في كتير قصص بتاثر على
الموضوع بس اوقات بتلاقي عمل مشترك وعليه
انتاج ضخم ناس ما بتوصل لقلوب الناس ولا
ما حتى بتاخد اكسبورجر او يعني اوقات بكون
عمل بسيط وهيك مشتغلين عليه بانتاج اقل بس
كمان بيوصل يعني منه شرط هذا الحكي
وهالاعمال يلي بتنعرض على التلفزيون
بكونوا الناس يلي منهم قادرين يشتركوا
مثلا بمنصات على المنصات بكونوا عم
بيحضروها ببيوتهم يعني نحن عم نفوت على
بيوت الناس فكمان في لذه يعني بهذا
الموضوع وليه غنيتي تحديدا التتر في
المسلسل هذا
وين او على فكره يعني
الناس اللي هني قراب ما تصدقون كلهم حتى
الصدق
كذاب على الغدر
بيدلون الناس اللي
قراب ما تصدقون كلهم حتى الصدق
كذاب على الغدر بيدل
خلينا نقول لك لموضوع ثاني كمان حلو جدا
انت ان شاء الله يعني خلينا نقول انت
عروسه عشرين ثلاثه وعشرين خلينا نشوف بس
لقطات سريعه من احتفال بخطوبتك
[موسيقى]
يا اللي بتستحي
اعطي قلبي
[موسيقى]
بنرجع طبعا للعروس مريتا الف مبروك الف
مبروك متل الفرح
شكرا شكرا ميرسي
متى الفرح ان شاء الله
نعم مثل الفرح الفرح يعني
هالسنه ان شاء الله ان شاء الله قريبا
هالسنه كيف كانت الاحاسيس يعني شفنا
الاحتفال فيك وكده وحسينا انه يعني طبعا
والدك كل التحيه طبعا كل التحيه لعائلتك
يعني كلهم نجوم بس حسينا والدك يعني جدا
متاثر كيف كان تقبله لانه في عريس جاي
ياخذ بنته
يعني اكيد البيه بتعرفه بيكون معلق
باولاده يعني بنته بالاخص وانا اول بنت
واول حدا بيتزوج بالبيت
فصعبه لاله انه كنا عم بترك البيت وبحس
يعني ما فينا كتير نحكي بالموضوع لانه
بنتاثر اكيد بحس هو يعني بفضل انه يلا ما
ضروري كثير نفوت بالتفاصيل
بس مبسوط يعني بحبه كثير لانه لخطيبه كميل
هو بحبه كثير ومبسوط فينا يعني هلا هلا
تقبل الموضوع اكثر واكثر بعد الخطبه خلص
صار بلش يفرح اكتر
قدامه الموضوع صار شويه يتقبل يعني هي
مشاعر مختلطه بيننا بين الفرح لا يعني
مبسوط لالي انا لقيت شخص المناسب وعم بكف
عامل حياه حلوه وبانه هو وزعلان انه يشتاق
له يعني انا قلت له راح ضل عندك كمان راح
ضل اكيد طبعا ما في ما في بنت بتترك يعني
ابوها بس اكيد تابعت الاهتمام اللي صار
شفنا الفيديوهات
الاحتفال في الخطوبه صارت رد كل شيء صار
ترند ملابسك ملابس اختك ملابس مامتك كل
احد في ناس اتكلموا على الفستان اللي كنتي
لابستيه قالوا انه مريتا كانت لابسته في
فيديو كليب من قبل هل هذا الكلام صحيح
وبعدين عملوها انه يي كيف ماريتا بتعيد
الملابس يعني حسسونا انه الموضوع عيب وانه
ما حد بيعيد الملابس ابدا وكلنا جالسين
بالعيد ملابسنا يعني بس انه بدي اياك يعني
بس تتكلمي عن هذا الموضوع اذا تردي عليهم
هلا اكيد اول شيء انبسطت كثير بكل التهاني
يعني كل الرسائل اللي وصلتني من الناس
واهتمامهم محبطهم الكبيره وبموضوع الفستان
انا عارفه انه لبسته من قبل ولبسته مره
لانه فستان بحبه وما عندي مشكله يعني
فستان موجود عندي وبحبه بلبسه وما فيك ترد
الناس يعني دائما بضل في شيء بده ينقال
يعني اذا لبست شيء جديد بدهم يحكوا اذا
لبستي شي لبستي بدهم يحكوا فانه مش مشكله
كل واحد عنده رايه وفي كل الاحوال اصلا ما
شاء الله عليك يعني انت حلوه والقالب غالب
ولو ايش ما لبستي اصلا حلو والفستان كان
حلو وكلنا بنعيد ملابسنا فانا حبيت انك
تردي على هذا الموضوع لانه
كيف يعني بتعيد الملابس لا كلنا بنعيد
الملابس لازم نعترف بهذا الموضوع يعني طيب
لا انا انبسطت على فكره لا كان في تعليقات
كثير حلوه انه كانت الناس عم بتقول انه
بالعكس هذا الشيء حلو وانا بتقصد ايام انه
اعمل هيك شي لانه في كتير بنات يعني اوقات
كمان نحن عم نقطع بظروف صعبه يعني عنا وفي
بنات يمكن انه لا عادي مش غلط لو على
خطبتك ولا ولا مناسبه عيد ميلادك فيك
تلبسي شي لابستيه من قبل يعني
القصص سخيفه بالحياه بالنسبه لالي في قصص
في اشياء اهم بكثير فانا عم جرب يمكن اوصل
كمان رساله من خلال هذا الشيء
ممتاز جدا طيب نحن بنشكرك جدا على وجودك
معنا اليوم مريض وبنتمنى لك كل التوفيق
ومبروك المسلسل والبطوله وان شاء الله
تكسري الدنيا وان شاء الله الفرح يكون
احلى فرح وتكوني احلى عروسه ان شاء الله
شكرا لك
ميرسي كتير انا انبسطت معكن وكل سنه وانتم
بخير وانت بخير
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا الشاهد حبوا يحتفلوا ببدايه
الشهر مع نجوم مسلسلات المنصه ويعايدوا
الجمهور باغنيه لطيفه وفكرتها مختلفه
بعنوان لا تنتهي الحكايات
[موسيقى]
لا تنتهي حكايات لا تنتهي
حكايات
عشينا عمران فوق عمر حكايه حلوه
تنسي
الحياه حياه
[موسيقى]
واحده لا تكفي
احيانا مرات رمضان
سيجمعنا مهما
[موسيقى]
تبى الدنيا موعدنا
فاذا زرناكم حدوده والممنه اهلا وبيوتكم
رمضان معنا
[موسيقى]
رمضان
مشاهدينا في امان الله